[Music]  maybe it's time Olivia  [Music]  [Applause]  hey it's time to do  [Music]  Dick's love to change main pillar Diggs  love to try  you know in the old days I always knew  like you were gonna do something that  you'd be all right it's the first time  I'm worried about you can I ask you a  personal question  okay tell me something good do you write  songs or anything  I don't sing my own songs why I just  don't feel comfortable why wouldn't you  feel comfortable almost every single  person has told me they like the way I  sounded but that they didn't like the  way I look I think you're beautiful  Hey what I just want to take another  look at you and all the good times I  find myself  [Music]  bojay isn't gonna do become sing that  song but I love no I can't do that  nice Justin  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  with  Michelle  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you